you
we have actually a really great group of
speakers here who represent a lot of
different aspects of social commerce and
so what I wanted to do is start off by
having let's start off with Brian at the
end there who is when the founders of
Airbnb and is definitely in the anti
portfolio for floodgate we actually
heard the pitch for Airbnb right before
they went live in the Democratic
convention whenever I'm asked which
company I regret not investing in the
number one answer for me is Airbnb so
bring on the pain yeah introduction tell
us a little bit about your company a
little bit about your background
excellent so yeah I'm Brian Chesky I'm
one of the founders and CEO of Airbnb
comm we are a community marketplace
where you can list and book all sorts of
unique spaces around the world like to
say anything from a private apartment to
a private island so it's all sorts of
spaces from a night to a year we're in
ten thousand cities travelers came last
year from every country on the planet
but North Korea in the Congo so we're
literally in 192 countries around the
world and you know we really started in
New York City we started getting a lot
of traction about two years ago and it's
really taken off since then and we're in
you know you know about 10,000 cities
and we this is a business that was
somewhat serendipitously started I you
know had moved up from Los Angeles to
San Francisco about three years ago and
we weren't able to I with my college
roommate at the time and we weren't able
to make rent and Design Conference was
coming to San Francisco all the hotels
design commerce were sold out and I had
originally quit my job and I think I had
a thousand dollars in the bank count
this is October 2007 so probably not
like really good planning obviously and
I was um and I get to San Francisco and
I realized rent was one thousand one
hundred and fifty dollars so they
already had a math crime right there and
we didn't know what to do this
conference was coming to San Francisco
all the hotels are sold out we had the S
idea why don't we create a
bed-and-breakfast
for the conference and that was the
vision so the vision there was nobody
and the vision was let's make rent for
the month October that was that was a
business plan basically and so um we
created I told Joe we don't have any
furniture so we can't create a
bed-and-breakfast he said well Brian we
have a few air beds in the closet we
blew up some air beds we called it the
air bed and breakfast we it was a
temporary bed and breakfast we ended up
making I think like a thousand dollars
by hosting a bunch of people that week
and that was supposed to be it and over
the next few months
people started like saying they love to
use the site or they it would be awesome
if they could go somewhere and use it so
I don't know how long just keep it kind
of so yeah so I'm not gonna go in the
full story except to say that um we
start our business to solve our own
problem and our own problem was to make
rent and we'd like to say what started
as a living room and air bed and a
living room has now spread to 10,000
cities around the world so high yeah
Greg Vance I am the chief marketing
officer of One Kings Lane
I joined late last year after ten years
at at eBay in a wide variety of roles
over ten ten years in marketing general
management and and products that saw
quite a few things happen over the
course of the 2000s and prior to that
we're two coca-cola in classic kind of
classic market and classic brand
management we're a company founded just
about two years ago by Susan Feldman and
Alison Pincus really focused on the home
and living space and we're does laser
focus on driving deep and delivering on
the consumer needs and also the industry
needs in a very fragmented industry
that's been very challenged with the
downturn of the economy well grounded in
sales events but you've probably seen
over time that we're growing into new
forms of e-commerce better ways to serve
products to our our consumers and really
delivering a great curated branded
experience in many many interesting ways
and really trying to weave commerce and
content together tell an interesting
story and then attach products around
those those stories which really I don't
think has been done it was sort of the
promise of the Internet in the early
2000s we're gonna try to crack that with
a deep focus on on home and living my
name is Brett Garrett of Bain Capital
ventures which is a venture and growth
equity investment arm of Bain Capital
we're kind of deeply involved in lots of
social and e-commerce and social
ecommerce come
he's from LinkedIn to rent the runway
which is that kind of a high-end dress
rental the Netflix of dresses we like to
call that the fine which is a vertical
search for shopping by with me which is
a group buying website and we're looking
to invest a lot more so I'll be
representing the the BC part of the room
my name is Brett Kensei man Oh eight
grad of the GSB and I work with Groupon
I am a my official title is director of
social I'm in the product management
group and my background is primarily in
social so building sort of apps on the
Facebook platform on the Twitter
platform and I grew up on I do a lot of
new product development and last I'm
Anne Meara Co I'll be moderating the
session I'm an investor at floodgate and
I've invested in a couple social
commerce companies in our portfolio we
have a company called Chegg which is
textbook rentals and I'm also on the
board of ModCloth which is a good
example of social commerce and fashion
space so I wanted to kick off this
conversation there's a lot of different
opinions as to what social commerce
means everyone talks about social
commerce but they they seem to be
talking about it in a lot of different
ways so I wanted to go down this group
and just just tell us from your
perspective what are some of the
defining characteristics of social
commerce yeah I mean social commerce is
definitely a big buzzword these days I
think the way I think about it and I
think the way we think about a Groupon
is a lot of the way that Facebook
defines sort of this concept of a graph
right so a lot of people will say you
throw a Facebook Connect on a website
and now I've got social commerce well
that's that's not really fundamentally
well how it works it's not just about
sort of virality and sharing through the
newsfeed to your friends whenever you
buy something that's not truly social I
think it's you have to figure out what
your business is and what the nodes
within your business are for us it's
local businesses and consumers and how
we connect those to through commerce
through a transaction right so that's
that's primarily how I think about
social commerce
and permissions play a big part of that
so the permission of how you can engage
with the consumer how you can get them
to you know be open to receiving
messages or want to receive these sort
of messages that's really what Facebook
I think has done the best of out of
anyone in enabling these you know this
two-way communication channel between
friends and the same thing applies for
local businesses it applies to home
manufacturers applies to people who have
an apartment or an air bed-and-breakfast
that they want to connect with you know
other consumers so that's that's kind of
how I think about it yeah I think I
would agree with that and I think you
know in general socially converse is a
pretty you know unuseful label because
it is so broad and so kind of you know
undefined but I think within it they're
you know really interesting businesses
and they're really uninteresting
business in terms of what social
commerce is and so I think you know
there's one social commerce where you
just take your business and you have
Facebook Connect and now social commerce
and there's another where you're really
doing something new you're either taking
you know social activities offline
you're kind of facilitating facilitating
them through the web somehow or you
create totally new behaviors like Airbnb
they are only possible because of the
web and you're able to kind of create a
commerce platform that way you know with
social social connections and so I think
you know in that spectrum I think the
more interesting ones are the ones where
you know you're not just you know
sticking some kind of you know Facebook
Connect or some social kind of label on
something that you're already doing but
you're really kind of imagining
something very new and something that's
available to do only now because there
is a social graph that you can leverage
so I make that distinction it's the same
opinion I make the basics is wiring you
set up to share is really just the
basics but how we're thinking about
things is how do consumers really start
influencing our shelves in real time how
does our inventory shift as our consumer
needs shift around that how do we really
co-opt our consumers into becoming our
sales force our merchandising team our
customer support team is how you incent
them how do you arm them how you
encourage them authentically to go to
work on your behalf because they love
your brand
companies have really done that well
authentically that's the magic word is
scale authentically cost-effective and
well there has been a big fixation for
all the right reasons on Facebook and
Twitter because the network effects
they've created we're equally as
interested in the tales of social media
where two enthusiasts live the web the
forums the blogs the places where they
talk about what they love and I think
you're gonna see more folks starting to
push out there with new technologies to
really try to scale out into the details
of social media because of the enormous
power out there and so I think it's the
early days quite honestly a lot of fun
stuff is gonna happen over the next
several years I think we think of social
commerce as very distinctive FEV and it
means bringing online offline so we feel
like a lot of things before Airbnb meant
bringing offline online and we think
everybody is very much bringing online
offline and you know we are now
connecting millions of people around the
world it's actually really cool because
we can create a world map and show which
countries we've connected to other
countries and Americans were connected
with residents in 90 different countries
last year I believe Australians are
connected with people in 60 different
countries and we can go country by
country and look if you kind of bring
those all together almost every single
country's been connected with another
country on the planet with - the two
coaches I mentioned and it's very
intimate social commerce and our sense
is very intimate because there's three
really intimate things that you can do
online or offline the first thing is
that you're paying somebody else money a
financial transaction is a very intimate
transaction so you're paying money
another thing you're doing is you're
meeting people in real real life that
you don't know it's the idea of meeting
somebody in the real world that you met
on the internet 10 years ago there was
even a stigma to that I think it's
pretty accepted today where we're
combining that with money we're adding a
third thing and a third thing is now
you're in the home with the person so if
you combine those three things that is
incredibly unique kind of intimate
transaction yeah I think that's a great
point I think one of the customers for
one of our portfolio companies Zimride
said my life becomes more interesting
when I opened my door and I thought that
would really capture this notion of what
a lot of people are calling
elaborate of Commerce or the social it
caught the sharing economy and I thought
what I'd love to do is dive a little bit
more deeply into that concept Brian
around what is it about today that makes
this kind of sharing and collaborative
culture possible yeah we we've been
struggling with that in a sense when
people hear about our concept well it
depends I think in 2007 we people heard
about a concept they thought are you
crazy
so that was the general that was I think
what my mom said and what my friend said
so of course they don't stay at the time
they say it like a year later like let
me tell you what I really thought
because it's time they're like really
supportive oh that's excellent you're
later like yeah I thought you were crazy
so there were things that I think had to
happen on the internet before you could
do all those kind of intimate things in
other words you had no you could argue
how to do all those three things in our
website to do all those three things
distinctly so paying other people that
happens on eBay before eBay you know
that was there was a huge stigma to
doing that and people were not
comfortable there today people wouldn't
buy anything online let alone pay
another person online so that had to
happen meeting people from the internet
15 years ago that or like you know even
10 years ago that was really you know
there's a huge stigma today not a big
deal and sharing space of people from
online that happens every day on
Craigslist maybe you get your your
roommate right a lot of people is room
probably fell or maybe after you're a
tree you'll find roommates on Craigslist
average person probably has so air maybe
I think in many ways just picked all
three of those and they converge them so
they're already doing it but we had to
allow all these other websites to kind
of happen first and then you kind of
bring them all those unique things
together
what about trust yeah so so I think
that's one of the other reasons I think
Trust is the currency of our marketplace
and the way our site works is you know
you can book space of people or stay
with people all over the world and Trust
is the mechanism that allows that you
know we allow you to connect to Facebook
you can see who their friends are
the real key though is the reviews
they're transactional based reviews so
after you stay with somebody you
a transactionally based review that's a
quantitative score various things about
them and they leave a reciprocal review
we have 24/7 customer support and as we
build this user base of profiles with
reviews you're basically building a
trusted community marketplace it's a
currency that over time now it's really
hard to get going because no one really
wants to be the first person without a
review to book another person without a
review and so there's really a long
story of why everybody took a really
long time to get going and now we have
hundreds of thousands of reviews one of
the new features we're going to be
coming out with to allow you if you
don't yet have our reviews you can
self-select a saying I want to stay with
Stanford alumni around the world so
maybe going to Tokyo well they're
probably some standard alumni that we
can connect you to as well so trust can
come through being earned or it can come
through affinity groups as well so
communities is a really I feel like
that's also in some ways with One Kings
Lane what's really interesting is that
you guys are really focused on one
particular vertical and having a lot of
credibility within that vertical and I
just want to dive a little bit more
deeply into that concept have you guys
thought about moving into other
verticals and why did you pick this one
in particular yeah actually we haven't
laser focused by the founders saying we
want to drive deep and really truly
deliver on the needs of consumers in the
home and living category versus I came
from eBay where we sold everything to
everybody and it's daunting it's hard to
deliver a really rich experience in a
given category if you got a cert 50 60
70 categories and so we're very laser
focused on this category in large part
because it's incredibly fragmented on
the retail side these folks really felt
the pain when the economy turned down
particularly the high end of the
industry those brands collapsed the
magazine's collapsed they're looking for
a solution to sell their goods to
consumers without degrading the brand
experience and really needed a place
like One Kings Lane just like gilt
groupe is done in the apparel industry
they need a place to move their
merchandise while they keep their brand
high and really well thought of and on
the consumer side it's challenging for
consumers as well yes most consumers
what their design tastes are and they
say eclectic because they don't know
that's basically I don't know what they
are and so what they're looking for is
people to help them
them puréed give them a sense of how
they can build things out one at a time
make it less intimidating really certain
to democratize the industry which by the
way fashion was democratized ten years
ago the internet really ripped it out
into mainstream didn't happen in home
that's what we're really looking to do
is make it a whole lot less intimidating
on the consumer side the buyer side and
really be a solution to the to the
retail side which is challenge right now
it feels like particularly for groups
like gilt groupe or One Kings Lane and
I've seen this with a ModCloth one of
the things that develops a brand is
actually a point of view as to what your
brand should be about and it's something
that differentiates these types of
e-commerce companies from what I call
you know commerce 1.0 where you're
creating essentially database of all the
products that could be sold as an Amazon
it feels like there's there's a strong
tie between this curation concept and
social commerce what do you think is
that that time yeah I mean I think
curation is the secret sauce and we
actually as a company one of the first
things I did when I got there the
founders said really bring our brand to
life articulated put it on paper
dimensionalize and so as we hire new
people we get bigger we don't lost lose
sight of who we are and in what we're
all about and that's kind of rare for
for four companies the challenge is
coming from eBay it was not curated
trying to curate that's tough it's
easier to start with a very tight
experience and walk and walk and walk
and get more power so that consumer make
it more social allow consumers to sell
to other consumers and that's you know
we're where everyone aspires to do it's
just really hard to do tight curation
and scale and that's the magic if you
can make both of those work which I
think Aaron be B and B is doing a
phenomenal job of making them both work
that is really the solution and I I'm
biased that I think driving deep in
categories being very focused on a
narrow set of consumers and segments is
a is a winning solution going forward so
challenge that notion grand you guys
have really sort of expanded really
really fast
it doesn't it doesn't necessarily feel
like there's really a lot of curation
how do you how do you think that think
through that kind of social commerce do
you want to move in a more curated
direction or do you want to just kind of
provide offers to the masses yeah and
the interesting thing is it may not be
as well-known but we actually do a lot
of curation so we have a editorial staff
of probably you know 100 or more people
that are writing up daily deal write-ups
on a daily basis and that's just a lot
of content I think there's a stat out
there about how much content is created
by editorial team and it's something
like you know thousands of newspapers
worth on a daily basis for every deal
that we run in every city we're in so
curation is is something that we we sort
of value fairly highly you know the
trust factor you were talking about
we are curators of local experiences so
we have to pick out the best ones we use
other review sites as well and and look
at you know what the reputations of
those businesses are elsewhere as well
as in discussing with them to determine
just how good those businesses are but
you know end of the day when someone
buys a Groupon they expect it to be a
great experience and if the local
merchants can't deliver on that because
of whatever reason whether it's our
fault or not you know we suffer for that
so we try to be very careful in terms of
making sure the merchants are ready for
the onslaught of customers they have
making sure that they are do actually
provide good experiences but then
there's the challenge of growth so then
how do you continue to grow when you're
curating so heavily and I think that's
just something that you know our
business and you know One Kings Lane and
we all have to deal with as we're trying
to create a great customer experience
while still you know growing massively
over geographies and internationally and
and over categories so the best thing is
everyone thought the solution of
curation was math algorithms to tell you
to do everything I think that's where
everyone went wrong and this notion of
personalization and curation is really
balancing the editorial and the
algorithm so you gotta get both right
that's where the secrets gonna come it's
just really hard to make the math
working scale in this way and coupons
doing so well is they're balancing the
both sides of the equation and really
doing some amazing things
I think one of the things that I always
I see in entrepreneurs is that that they
because I teach mostly in the
engineering school a lot of these
students come in thinking that the
computers can solve the problems and one
of the most compelling parts of MSE
ModCloth in particular was there was a
woman there who really understood the
community and the customer she was
selling to so I think that's that's
definitely a core component now you know
we've looked through sort of three
different types of the social commerce
business I'd love to ask Brett in terms
of when you think about investing in
these types of companies then we've
looked at curations kind of concept of
collaborative commerce and what makes
that successful even with these sale
sites the concept of community and and
how communities will also help these
couponing sites how do you think about
evaluating these types of companies
what's the most important component for
you right so there's not one component
that's you know it stands out kind of
head shoulders but above everything else
but I think there are some themes that
were you know general very excited about
I think you know the three panelists
here that are operators I think really
represent some of those themes I'd say
one of the biggest things we're excited
about in terms of social ecommerce
really is kind of a Brian said earlier
which is taking the paradigm from
bringing people on the internet taking
people off the internet and so you know
Airbnb in a lot of ways I think was on
an unlikely inaugural company to do this
because of all the you know miracles I
think Brian had to overcome but we're
seeing lots more marketplaces that the
internet enables social commerce on but
is not really you know on the Internet
in the traditional way so you know some
examples of that are a company called
thredUP based in San Francisco which
enables parents to you know send each
other boxes of clothes when their kids
outgrow them so it's taking a very
social practice that happened long
before there was an Internet people
would say oh my you know two-year-old
five-year-old seven-year-old just grew
these clothes I'm now waiting for an
in-law or someone else to give them to
but now the internet empowers this
practice and you can share with only
Stanford alumni are only people of you
know in a certain groups or everybody
and there's these platforms now where
the Internet's touching that in a little
bit I mean in the sense it's not
happening on the Internet's happening
kind of in people's houses as I packed
all the boxes and proud labels but it's
the Internet vic wa tiss lee letting
this happen and so things like thread up
things like get around or relay rides
which are kind of like the Airbnb for
cars so there's this collaborative
consumption again you know through the
mobile device allowing the internet to
kind of you know you go through this
whole platform and enables to happen of
people even going on a webpage and
surfing around in kind of a social
experience and so I think those type of
marketplaces that are inherently social
that are happening offline are really
interesting from a vessel perspective
because a their marketplaces and they're
really stable and hard to dislodge over
time but be they're you know taking
behavior that you know it's just really
kind of has been happening for a long
time and making it more powerful and
more extensible in lots of ways so I
think that's one thing that's been
really exciting there's other themes too
but I think that's kind of next
generation of social e-commerce I saw
Brian you're smiling when he was saying
it's the Airbnb of something like that
that means you you really know you've
made it when people are saying when we
launched we said we were the eBay of
space it's funny how we came up with
that name so we did Y Combinator you
guys probably know about Y Combinator
exists he doesn't like to call himself
an incubation I guess you could say he's
it's this kind of seed program where
they give you $20,000 and it has a bit
of a collegial feel there's like
typically 20 or 30 companies that will
enter twice a year to this 12-week
program every week there's a notable
speaker and the this all leads to this
final day called demo day so leading up
to demo day we were trying to explain
what we were and I remember Paul Graham
people at the time couldn't get their
heads around if there was a real
business here and there's notably like
couch surfing a lot of people originally
thought we were like couch surfing now
today we have a lot of homes we have we
have like really big spaces we have
castles we even have cars and boats and
all sorts of spaces but back then it was
mostly bedrooms you know and air beds
and living rooms and so Paul Graham says
you should say you're the eBay of space
because ebo is a marketplace they were
really big they're a billion dollar
company and never enough space it was so
matter-of-fact I'm like yeah we're the
eBay space and at the time we weren't we
I don't know be really like think could
say me word because we're pretty much
the eBay of bedrooms but now we really
are have moved into any type of unique
space and they think we like to say is
if eBay to become a billion dollar
company but monetizing the stuff in your
home well how big could have company be
if they monetize the home which is
basically 25% of you know assets and the
backyard the front yard all those could
basically all that all that kind of
space and the one other thing maybe I'll
say just a follow-up on Brett's point
was I think in many ways social commerce
is the way things always were and the
way they will be and I think it was kind
of post-world war two there was this
period of maybe 60 years at least in our
space where it wasn't like that and the
story goes like this so we came up with
a concept I told my mom about it my
mom's probably 59 years old baby boomer
and she thought we were crazy and most
of her friends probably thought we were
crazy I told my late grandfather about
it my great father grew on my
grandfather grew up in the Great
Depression and he said of course and I
go what do you mean of course well he
had done this when he was growing up of
course there was no internet but there
weren't modern hotels like we know today
people would stay in bed and breakfast
and inns or in private residences the
word southern hospitality you know
really means like taking people into
your homes and they have that symbol a
pineapple it's a simple hospitality
these two have pineapples the ends of
your bed so in other words this is how
people have been traveling since
biblical times it's you know a hotel
hundred years ago look like a bed and
breakfast today a bed and radical
engineers gay look like Airbnb today and
so you know it was really I think 1960
that like a Marriott like our Hilton
started really taking off so this idea
that like we're the new way was kind of
true but the same time it's what people
were doing for a really long period of
time and I think for a period of time
there was this idea that strangers were
being connected from so many different
places and there was this absence of
trust and a reputation incurring any
kind of currency and I think finally all
those things came back together and now
you're seeing all these things happen
and it feels like it's a rich space for
a lot of different types of startups I'm
popping up which is why we're seeing
sort of the Airbnb of lots of different
times just one thing to that setting
it's the interesting point you know
related to the fact that this is how
things used to be
I think a lot of social businesses can
be proven out by entrepreneurs at an
early stage without any technology at
all so one really interesting example of
that is the Rent the Runway story where
Jen and Jenny has idea to be the Netflix
of kind of aspirational dresses so
instead of buying a $1,500 dress you can
rent that dress for $100 through Rent
the Runway those sent to your house well
they had this idea coming out of Harvard
Business School and when they met with
us you know we basically said prove it
and they said well we have to hire all
these engineers we have to build this
front end with builders back home so no
no don't do that
just go to and you you pick the venue
but they decided to do it at sorority
parties at Yale Harvard Princeton and
they showed up at Surrey parties in
advance they had sent out invitations to
rent dresses they showed up with you
know small inventory dresses just to
test to see if people would pay money to
rent the dresses what happened to a
dress at a sorority party how it came
back you know could it be reused you
know lots of things they learned without
any technology at all and so I think a
lot of these social proof points can you
really proved out and I because I think
the technology is what lets it scale
massively but it the technology's never
usually never you know the business in
itself and so I think that was really
interesting anecdote I think it applies
a lot of social commerce businesses yeah
very similar story with Chag when we
were Chad came from pivot out of
Craigslist for colleges basically and
Facebook came out with Craigslist and so
we were like okay well we can't really
beat Craigslist for colleges anymore and
they they had this idea well everyone is
exchanging textbooks on this site and so
let's try to pivot there so instead of
creating a whole new site with the check
brand on it they they created a site
called textbook flicks and then what we
did was we got an Amazon Prime account
and kids would come in I think we had a
thousand students that first quarter
come in try to rent a textbook we buy it
off of Amazon and ship it for free out
to these students and they would call
and say
just got a box from Amazon yeah just
send it back to us when you're done
and it was extraordinarily successful
from that perspective we got to test out
exactly as was mentioned here by Brett
whether or not students would return the
textbooks what what state did they
return it in and being able to test all
that hypotheses out before really even
launching the business was
extraordinarily valuable so I think
that's very much true for a lot of these
types of businesses just proving out by
Airbnb another question then going back
to one Kings Lane it's a little bit of a
different type of business with Airbnb
but I wanted to go back to this notion
that you are talking about how you would
use your community actually help inform
some of the backend of your business and
I think that's that's a really
interesting concept because it feels
like social commerce then what you're
saying is not just people coming in
buying stuff it's actually some of the
information that they're providing you
to help you optimize your business I'd
love to hear a little bit more about
that Sherman what do they think is going
to try to do over the next year or so is
more of our merchandising in the site we
do it all ourselves and it's beautiful
it's very expensive to do it looks great
but we want our consumers to do the
merchandising so more user generated
content because I can tell a story and I
could paint a picture of a room if I can
get a consumer to do the same thing it's
much more powerful it's much more
authentic it's much more real and so
over time the site will come more from
our consumers than merchandising the
aspiration all the ideas will come from
them because consumers actually a more
trust in other consumers who share
like-minded interests than they do in
folks like us they love our stuff they
trust people who are like them and so
more and more the look in the field of
merchandising it appears on the site the
recommendations you name it will come
from our consumer base and we think it's
very powerful and again it goes back to
the notion that no one has really
cracked the notion of amazing content
and amazing content woven it together to
probably context that in surprise really
inspires surprises and delights
consumers and I think that's the next
wave you're going to see and again it's
not math it's math and editorial woven
together and we think the editorial from
our consumers is much more powerful
great and then Brett going back to then
the concept of Groupon feels like
there's just with the wild success of
Groupon there's been billion other
Groupon clones that have been born how
as a company do you hit stay ahead of
that do you think that there's room for
everyone or as as there's more
competition does that create problems
for a business like Groupon how do you
guys think about that yeah I mean
there's definitely been a lot of
companies that have pivoted this space
whether they were in it to begin with
and you know they're companies such as
Yelp or even Google kind of coming in
and and trying to be in the space I
think you know tell us that's that's a
you know it's sort of flattery I guess
in some sense because the the company
has done so well I think the thing we
hear from the merchants standpoint
that's very interesting is that you know
as a merchant now locally you get calls
from countless daily deal sites all the
time and so well well you know some of
the fatigue on the user standpoint for
how many emails can you actually
subscribe to a deal they deal emails
there's sort of a question there you
know it doesn't take that long just to
read an email you know on the merchant
side to engage with a salesperson from
ten different daily deal sites that can
be really tiring and so I think there's
you know that it's there's an
interesting dynamic going on why or
there may be a hundred copycat companies
in the Bay Area they're all calling on
the same merchants you know sort of we
want to work with and that we have
worked with and and to certainly send
these merchants you know they they want
to work with us because they need new
customers but they need to be dedicating
99% their time to running their business
and making sure that that's profitable
and making sure that it's running well
you know a daily deal site for them is a
way to acquire new customers that oil
that come back in the door time and time
again but they can't spend too much time
you know working with us we need to make
it really easy for them and so I think
the more sort of options there are for
them you know the more it actually helps
us to a certain extent and in order to
help some of the leaders in the space
that have larger subscriber lists that
are at a greater scale than some of the
people
have looked at the model and said oh
that's so easy I just need to start
selling local businesses and then
quickly sort of learned well there's
there is actually a network effect here
it's just localized it's not it's not
the same network effect that's it played
eBay it's all within San Francisco it's
all within Palo Alto it's all within
Chicago so I think there's some dynamics
out there that some people talk about
but don't really think through all the
way that I think will contribute to you
know having having scale as an advantage
for us across multiple marketplaces but
if each merchant is getting you know 10
15 calls from every other coupon site is
that does that make it a race to the
bottom in terms of margins for companies
like yours or is it you know one or two
survivors will really emerge in terms of
we have the big subscriber base and so
therefore that's what we offer yeah I
think the subscriber base is the key
thing there you know for them again I
think that it's more about I want to be
able to get the right number of
customers in and sort of the right
cadence and sort of less about the
margin itself these merchants are ones
that again they can operate they know
they operate good businesses they know
once they get someone in the door that
they can convince them to come back in a
lot of times you know very local
merchants so it's not like it's not as
much like a Taco Bell where you know the
person that's sort of serving them you
know doesn't get to know that customer
that they take pride in every customer
that comes in their door they want to
get to know them that's where that sort
of social aspect you know it's funny you
were mentioning how it used to be like I
think of a lot of ways what we do
socially is we sort of give these local
merchants the ability to reconnect with
their local consumers in a way that
hasn't been seen in in the United States
and a long time you know I lived in
Spain for a year in 2004 and I became a
local at a bar and I'd never done that
in America I'd never gotten to know
someone that actually served me food and
gave me drinks and we were friends and
you know that's for us I think the
ultimate success for Groupon can we
create that sort of dynamic you know
through the internet through mobile in
sort of a local basis right we just to
tie that all back I think to this the
social discussion at one massive barrier
I think that Groupon can have at scale
is that bacon
push social promotions that are curated
because of your social graph and
basically drive better the right
consumers to the right merchants and the
right deals there are consumers in a way
that you know once you have that scale
you know upstarts can't do that well I
think that's definitely one really
exciting thing about you once you hit
scale doing group buying that you know
other people can't touch you so I think
that's a yeah I don't know if you guys
have proven out yet but I'm sure you're
working on that data you know that scale
and having the resources sort of take
that data and figure out what it means
and then apply it to your product and
you know that's something that we think
about a lot we spend a lot of effort on
yeah great so just sort of I wanted to
gather some final thoughts from each of
you on where do you think this all goes
over the next let's say two to three
years it feels like social commerce on
some levels have has reached a maturity
in terms of what it actually is but it
feels like there's also a lot more that
it can actually do and there's a big
promise aspect to social commerce so
before we turn it over to the audience
for questions I'd love to get your
perspectives on where does this all go
in the next 2-3 years start with brine
so yeah there's a line Oh a lot of
entrepreneurs that they are they have
slide decks you know in in your slide
deck you know in our slide deck we had
to make a giant guess on the marketplace
and we had to make a guess on would this
work and I'm pretty sure that a lot of
people now have our logos and their
slide decks and they say not I get
Google Alerts forever you me and you
know every every so often you'll see
every be four cars everybody four events
every me for food everybody for tutoring
so we're like proving this model now
which is really interesting I think that
we now that we've proven this at a
certain scale we it's really like open
up people's the door of their
imagination to all the other ways you
can connect and I really think it's all
these different industries I think for
every NBA the one thing I can say with
certainty is that it's gonna grow quite
significantly geographically we're a
site that was global from day one and
the reason we are global and it's very
different than Groupon we're a local but
we
locals together from around the world
it's not an insular community so
basically like we started in London
Paris New York people travel these
cities from tens of thousand seas around
the world and so it was the natural
built-in network effect that happened
where they came from these thousands of
cities around the world they booked they
stayed in New York they go back to
wherever they came from
and we remarket it to them essentially
and that's all it was and they would say
well you had a great experience you
should run your place you should tell
other people about it unless you're
homeless by definition you have space
you can run out under B&B that was
essentially what we had said to them and
it really started to grow and so I think
this is something that's spreading
internationally and even with our
platform it's spreading to like in two
different categories you know we see
ourselves not limited to bedrooms or
even necessarily houses we have many
people renting all different types of
spaces a few weird use cases that are
being facilitated today are when people
first move to a city now everybody's an
incredibly common use case let's say you
have to go to DC next week you just
found out you got a job in you're not
finding an apartment on Craigslist from
another another city to a different
Craigslist when you came in toward the
apartments and you have to rush like
that doesn't really work people use
their BB now for neighborhood sampling
now I want to try out a neighborhood
once a week and see what it's like so
that's really really common and there's
a lot of like unexpected things people
are even renting out other people's
homes for dinner parties which I thought
it was unbelievable so it's like why get
a really nice house in a small house and
then you want to press somebody rent a
big house today so you know to some
extent I guess what I'm going is we
think the platform allows people to
project what they want onto it so the
future for Airbnb and for these
marketplaces is if we create really
dynamic platforms people are gonna find
uses for it they're gonna realize I have
this we never thought like people even
put up their entire homes we never
thought people would put up tree houses
one day a professor at Harvard decided
to he we rented his house he had a tree
house in his backyard that he probably
built for his kids his kids with the
college one day he decides to rent out
his tree house his tree house is now
getting more bookings than the house and
the tree house has paid for the mortgage
on
house so when people rent out other
people's houses do they lie about it
being their house or do they what is the
dinner party I have absolutely no idea
about that one but I wouldn't be
surprised it's actually a really good
idea I like it'd be a great way to
impress a date Greg so I mean the notion
of maturity and social commerce I think
it's so early I think ecommerce overall
is really early stages I mean right now
the share of e-commerce overall retail
is the same as the catalogue business
which is which is somewhat embarrassing
I could say that because I've been in
this business for 10 12 years and I'm as
much a culprit as anybody else and I
think this is just gonna unlock things
that the internet was supposed to do ten
years ago we we think back and I was
supposed to be able to get an incredibly
personalized experience for me for
anyone in this room as relates ecommerce
that hasn't happened I think social
empowering more people to do that for
other people it's gonna really really
awaken and help grow ecommerce and new
and different special ways and it's a
lot about giving up control and allowing
consumers your social graph to build
your story for you so I think it's early
days I mean it's just getting started
but not just social commerce think
ecommerce it's just getting going in the
next couple years I think there's just
going to be things happening that have
not happened since the the early 2000s
so just an exciting time to be in the
space yeah I couldn't agree more with
those those thoughts I mean I think
we're definitely you know just at the
very beginning of a really exciting
phase almost like asking the question
you know what what is the you know the
future of personal computing 1980 it's
just stuff you can't even dream about
today and I think we've spent a lot of
time talking about Airbnb you know One
Kings Lane Groupon which are all you
know massively successful businesses but
from a venture perspective we've been
seeing different use cases that are
equally social and you know commercial
and kind of marry those two in totally
different applications so things like
you know there's I don't know how many
people are familiar with you know just
starts like fascism or go try it on
where you can basically take a picture
of yourself wearing something and
because there's enough users on the site
you get instant feedback on yeah
definitely buy that because you're in a
dressing room at Neiman Marcus or Macy's
and that kind of social feedback on that
one use case it's just really
interesting and so I think there's
everything from personalized closet and
kind of mobile devices enabling kind
real-time sharing both with your friends
and and to other people as you buy just
we haven't seen anyone really scratch
the surface on that so I think it's very
very exciting the next three plus years
it's definitely new I mean I think
there's two dynamics we're gonna see
expanding over time one is the sort of
enriching of that social dynamic so you
know in air BBS case what are those
interesting interactions that are
happening when the person is is at that
house and how do they how do they make
that experience better for both parties
for Groupon you know same thing how do
we how do we make that experience and
and better for each user and for each
merchants and then the second is really
just mobile and I think you touched on
it all the things that are coming out
with GPS with cameras front back what
are the things that you can build into
your product or new sort of interactions
that are made easier just by the fact
that you have this with you all the time
you know this is becoming the most
important device the most important
technology that there is you know people
get nervous they get anxiety if it's
actually taken away from them and so
what how can you use this device to
actually make things more social those
are really the two dynamics I see any
questions from the audience we have
when you start with these social
businesses how you how you went through
that initial stage of getting people to
buy into the idea start using the
service and get to the tipping point
where it starts to go viral when people
are thinking this is an amazing idea
well you referenced the tipping point
which i think is kind of a concept that
Groupon you know is fundamental the
Groupon early on and and the idea is
that unless we sold enough of a
particular deal of the deal wasn't
actually valid so your credit card
actually wouldn't be charged and tell
and still isn't charged until that
tipping point has met the incentive
though that creates then is to share
that on Facebook share that on email you
know share it on Twitter shared Sheryl
link via you know it's a message what
have you and so we you know we've
certainly we certainly used that
especially early on in order to try to
get past that tipping point and create
incentives basically just share things
you know that's definitely a huge part
of it so in our case the first hundred
users are mbb were related to one of the
founders so and that's that if you're
starting a website then you should force
your friends and family to sign up
because assume that whatever you make is
not good enough on day one to for people
that don't know you'd actually be
compelled to use it and so those people
are essentially your test subjects and
so just get your friends to use it
assume that you have a Minimum Viable
Product you know and we basically
launched four times and I think we met
and that was our third launch we
actually had a time when it was October
2007 two designers that engineer came up
with a really simple website March 2008
we had this notion we're gonna create a
website we can provide air beds for
conference around United States that
didn't really take off and in the summer
of 2008 we bought this we we built the
site you see today we we basically got
all of our friends and family to kind of
use it then we like sent out a little
blog post and all of our press and we
use press to get a lot of traction and
was always an inverse pyramid where you
start at the bottom and you work your
a national media doesn't in this in
startups aren't actually looking for
like necessarily breaking news like CNN
New York Times sometimes they are but
oftentimes what they're doing is they
want to reference things are already
popular so what you do is you start with
your friends your work your way out to
people who like friends of friends then
you go to small blogs you know it's easy
to get a small blog to write about you
because they don't get that many emails
a really big blogs harder and really big
blogs and write about you if the smaller
blogs other people are using you and so
then then you get to newspapers and you
kind of work your way up and we use the
Democratic National Convention to do
that it was June 2008 we had no idea we
had this platform it was a chicken-egg
prom
buyers want to go where sellers are
sellers want to go where buyers are it's
kind of like trying to get me try to get
all these people make stuff into your
store when no one's in your store like
no one wants to actually put stuff in
that store that was a problem we had and
we figured how do we actually solve this
and the way we decide to solve it was
press we Denver the June 2008 the thing
everyone was talking about was the
Democratic National Convention and
Barack Obama we figured this is a very
topical issue we can leverage this to
get a lot of press so I remember one day
we literally typed in DNC housing and
Google News all these reports were
reading about how the hotels are sold
out we're like this is the perfect way
for Obama spores to come together and
they had just moved him from the 20,000
seat Pepsi Arena to an 80,000 C football
stadiums there were thousands people
needed housing and we I probably emailed
800 people a day without exaggeration
like anyone would write about us first
only small bloggers then people in
Denver started listing then we got the
local news we literally called producers
at every local television show station
they started doing stories then the
Denver Rocky the Rocky Mountain News
Denver Post are doing stories within a
few weeks we went like CNN like call us
up they want to do an interview in our
living room which is the weirdest thing
in the world they like have CNN your
living room and you're like still an
entrepreneur entrepreneur no business
you're basically unemployed there's like
there's more of a state of mind before
you business right like I'm an
entrepreneur but you know
yeah you have to believe it so yeah so
and there's one final anecdote and that
was during Y Combinator Paul Buchheit
was one of the speakers and I Paul bucha
is the creator of Gmail and he also
coined Google's don't be evil mantra and
he is saying he said a website needs a
hundred people to love you before you
can take off he said it's really people
think they can find a hundred people to
love them it's really really hard
there's the websites to have been around
for ten years I've never found one tree
but love them I mean love and Gmail took
supposedly two years he said before he
could find a hundred people Google that
absolutely love the service and it
probably took the same for Airbnb one
slight build is one of the great thing
that the founders did at One Kings Lane
is focus on influencers there's a big
trend in marketing is in the valleys put
all your money in Google keywords
keywords keywords I've been focusing
your time your energy on creating
broadcast towers find the most
influential people in your space and
invest your time and energy and getting
them on your site let them tell your
message before you and I also like of
the motion there's a big guardrail
everything is data data data it's all
about the mind old school PR is an
incredible asset that I think a lot more
companies inga used it extraordinarily
well it's just old school PR tactics not
enough companies use it Mary the heart
in the mind to really build that wave
that buzz that can give a a catalyst to
your network effect yeah I think I've
left to add kind of operationally
because I think all these tactical
things and how you fight tooth and nail
to get users you know make a lot of
sense I think from a conceptual or
investor level there's a really nice
concept of social proof and I think it's
one of those things that I think you
know ex-ante you can say oh that's a
crazy idea who would do that and you
know who would do this thing called
Groupon you know why am I gonna give
them my credit card and sign up for this
why am I going to my house up to
strangers but it really doesn't take
that many people to have this viral
effect where you know someone who knows
someone who's just making a ton of money
on their tree house and then you know
that really all of a sudden sense 10
people to put their houses up for dinner
parties or you know for them to buy you
know high-end home decor online for them
to use Groupon so this idea of not only
a couple you
or 100 users who love you but how
quickly these social behaviors can
spread and get validation I think can
happen really quickly and so I think
there's this moment maybe kind of early
on where people are very skeptical and
maybe you were even skeptical as an
entrepreneur but you you know our
experience we've seen a lot of that
change really really quickly yeah I mean
just going back to what Brian said build
a great product and you build a great
product and it's so much easier than you
think and it sounds really easy to say
but you iterate until you have a very
product right you you go through three
four or five different iterations
getting you know abusing your friends
and family to try it out until they you
know they hate hate scene you know
hitting that your URL but eventually it
sort of snaps into play and and you see
that story time and time again with
startups with products know if anyone
knows Settlers of Catan the the man who
created that game literally spent 12
years building it and making his family
played every night and it was never fun
until the twelfth year and finally
finally his family was like okay this
game is really great and they started
actually having fun and he knew he had a
product and though
so basically well first of all I don't
know how mature we are but we're we're
more mature than we used to be you have
kind of two questions there one around
the consumer side of things one around
the merchants side of things the thing
the thing I think that's really
interesting from a product sense about
the concept of a deal or the word deal
is that a deal to a to a user is content
it's something that people enjoy you
know coupon clipping they like to read
about deals you get the circular the
best buy circular and sort of read
through it for fun on Sunday afternoon
into merchants an ad it's a it's a
promotion and so that creates a pretty
powerful dynamic between a merchant and
a user in sort of that communication
mechanism of what a sort of a deal is
specifically that word alone is just
really really powerful the social
dynamic as I said before I think is
really between the merchant and the
consumer and the transaction the
exchange of cash and in return for
services or goods you know that that
happens as part of commerce is the
primary most important sort of a link
between them you know the Facebook talks
about the graph in general and there's
all sorts of things that friends do to
each other they share photos with each
other they comment to each other on
their walls they email they send
messages between a merchant and a user
it's it's really about that transaction
and then there are other things
ancillary things that sort of surround
that so discussions or comments or
reviews or what-have-you but it's all
driving towards that one purchase so for
us the most important thing is that we
can drive those purchases so we drive
that primary
interaction get get users that love that
experience that you know it's around
where they live and therefore they've
seen it they're not familiar with it
they're likely to go back they talk to
the owner of that business and now they
feel a connection to it and on the
merchants standpoint you know the
hardest thing to do really is they get
users a lot of times I've seen this sort
of firsthand we recently moved to
Chicago last year and my wife has
started up a an education service so
it's sort of like a Montessori inspired
pre-k program and she has a great
product she's really smart it's an
incredible incredible product but she
literally just cannot find ways to get
people in the door and we tried going
around putting fliers everywhere we
tried to get coffee shops to sort of
send things that would be a newsletter
and nothing really worked except for
word-of-mouth nothing at all you know
even a free a free class and so I've
seen firsthand just how hard it can be
on a local basis to get merchants or to
get users in the door but once they do
that most of these mostly merchants are
sort of very successful I don't know
it's kind of a long window don't know if
that answers all of your questions but
we I think we know that once we build a
great product for for the consumer and
and and and then make sure the merchant
is happy and ninety eight percent of our
merchants want to work with us again
that's all we really have to do to be
successful
you know I don't virtual currency I
think on its own is in the way I'm
looking at it now and I definitely
experiment virtual currency but I see it
as kind of just something that removes
friction from a system like on Facebook
and having you know virtual currency
instead of having to trust every
merchant you can buy virtual currency
from Facebook and then use that and
that's fungible for everybody but I
don't see that necessarily accelerating
you know any social commerce you know
more than it would without virtual
currency I think it removes some
friction but I don't think it's you're
massively disruptive on its own
yeah I mean we're investing sort of more
and more overtime in into you know
different ways of sort of measuring it's
a really hard problem there's actually a
lot of I think very interesting startups
out there they're doing some interesting
things related to local analytics and
you know and again it all actually comes
back to this device so the only way you
can really sort of measure and track
someone is if they have sort of a
smartphone device that you can somehow
establish a signal with right at least
on sort of massive scale there are other
things around Redemption you know
redemption of a code or purchases you
know be a credit card what-have-you but
in a local space it's really hard
because everyone has different
point-of-sale systems and everyone
transactions slightly different ways and
so there's really no one
one-size-fits-all solution so you kind
of have to solve the problem from a
number of different angles and it's it's
something that's definitely very
important to us it's important for
merchants they have a sense for it if
they don't know the exact numbers and
you know we're definitely invested in it
Gregg UNT yeah I would say huge Evan I
think just unlock into creativity and
consumers and just setting it loose is
gonna be incredibly powerful inspiring
to other consumers to shop to navigate
we did research back when I was even it
said honestly consumers trust consumers
more than they trust third-party reviews
trust companies but no one has really
unlocked it and the key is once you do
that you have to kind of curate it
because you just don't want that massive
content where 80% of it is just really
bad and the 20 gets lost in there you
got to find the great content elevate
that shine the light on it but it's
incredibly powerful if you can get a
scalable content environment consumers
will love it and they're thirsting for
it they're saying more more MORE help me
get that information so very powerful I
think a good place to look for the
impact of that is like QVC or HSN where
you see consumers calling in or writing
in about different products and how that
impacts the sales on those sites it's
it's absolutely staggering and that's
what just cents done a great job of and
guys have 10 15 years ago they told a
story in this old product and that
really hasn't happened online is tell me
a story and then sell me things around
it inspire me drive serendipity really
hasn't happened scale beyond the
internet I think that's gonna start
happening more and more
so we've always seen it as just having a
a paper trail so before us you know you
know so the vacation rental industry is
a hundred billion dollar industry
worldwide a huge industry one of I think
five people when they travel down stay
in a hotel previous to us they were
staying in another person's home and the
way a typical homeowner like say you're
gonna use VR beyond you're gonna run out
your vacation home the things they used
to do is they'd ask for a copy of their
passport they would ask you to send them
a non-refundable deposit they'd have a
rental agreement and they usually want
to talk to you on the phone and all the
trying to do this kinda composite of who
are you why are you going there
and do I have some sort of like like
tracks about like who you are and so we
realized that even many ways was able to
prove this to some extent but eBay the
profiles are still with very
one-dimensional and they're not very um
they're not very robust so what we
decided was we are going to completely
round out the story we're gonna take the
profile from Facebook and associate it
with financial transactions and our
users connect to bank accounts to their
credit card processing you know payment
systems and through that we now have a
paper trail of who these people are you
know and so it's it's like it's like
walking down a wallet Street as long as
you can show who the people are and you
can associate it to like payment methods
then over time when you get that
cumulation of reviews then it really
rounds it out and I think of ourselves
as not necessarily create
platform for you knowing homes around
the world of staying what we're really
doing is creating a platform of trusted
profiles once you trust these people you
can exchange any type of Commerce
through that platform
you know it's reinforced not from eBay
exactly is transparency transparency
transparency more information the better
and you also can never take your eye off
the moment you take your eye off trust
you don't stop innovating you die and
it's hard to recover out of that and so
in a marketplace environment trust Trust
trust Trust trust it's the secret sauce
of what holds it and binds it all
together
that's the curation that secure a ssin
allowing people to score other consumers
and really elevating as much information
as possible and allowing that identity
to surface and more information more
transparent information is always always
the way to go but you have to be
involved in that you just can't sit back
and let it happen yet being active
actively manage the trust environment
with an ecosystem
we've now in the process of changing our
reviews from purely qualitative to
qualitative and quantitative in fact
when you leave a review now they're all
quantitative one through five stars and
I think seven different categories you
don't publicly show this yet we've been
collecting this data for about four
months now and that will be the next
iteration of what we're releasing with
reviews I think it really is the next
kind of level and the other thing we're
gonna start doing is when you leave a
review a strip is really a story and a
review is really a story of your
experience we started realizing people
would leave like three sentence reviews
on Airbnb but they didn't leave this
huge blog post about their trip doesn't
want to share with their friends or on
Facebook they had like 20 photos when
they went to Costa Rica we started
realizing what if those stories could
come through inside of the profile right
so what it's like when you left a review
you were really leaving a story you can
leave photos and I think that is going
to be the kind of the future of where
our review system starts to go is it
becomes much more robust as Gaia data
it's got more rich content
so I think that's really like the key of
it yeah I think just to add to that
within ModCloth what we were seeing
within the review site I was just
shocked at the amount of personal
information that people would reveal
like these women would say what their
bust size was and what their waist size
is and how big their what their hips are
and then they would say fits great on me
you know and then I would say well I
don't have that body type so I can't
possibly fit into that dress and so that
kind of the the willingness with which
people will share very personal
information like a blog post about their
trip isn't really surprising because
it's just sort of the modus operandi now
of people on the social web and I think
that's what's really adding to the
richness of what social commerce can
really be
much more targeted information much more
targeted coupons and what I suspect is
there actually and they have much more
information about many other things that
I check out what else so you know we
really focus on sort of product and our
consumers
you know experiences first and foremost
Yelp is a source of reviews for first
you know some of our consumers and and
they're really they do a really great
job of capturing that those user reviews
so but for us it's really about making
sure we're delivering the most relevant
deals to our users and and making sure
that we're delivering a lot of value for
our merchants and we sort of figure out
that everything else will figure itself
out as long as we do that well so I
can't really comment too much about Yelp
specifically or any other any other
player in the space
do you have a company in India with two
million users hypothetically I much add
there specifically around sort of how we
operationally look to expand either I'm
in the product groups I focused mostly
on the product yeah we haven't done any
positions we what we do do is there were
in tens of thousands of cities for
10,000 now we do prioritize where we
want to become dominant and so where we
want to put our resources so we made a
list of the most important markets for
us we said by the end of 2011 we want to
make sure even if there were competitors
they would not build unseat us in these
dominant markets it's like a giant game
of Risk and good kind of saying we want
to dance by this market in this market
we say Buenos Aires is really important
for us or Tokyo or Shanghai or Beijing
and in I think New Delhi is one of our
markets that we're focusing on this
summer so we you know we have a list of
markets and then we have various you
know marketing initiatives and then we
put our money and resources towards
these markets then we and the only other
thing is we try to find a diverse number
of markets now we're not interested in
dominating in just New York Boston DC LA
you know we want to dominate or we want
we want to just really use this as an
opportunity to learn about different
markets Seoul enter a market in like
Brazil will enter a Rio and will use
that to learn and then will realize that
we're in Buenos Aires and realize that
because the banking crisis link was a
2001 it's really hard for people to
accept payments and so in Argentina the
way we pay users is beyond PayPal and
international ACH we've actually are
coming with our own debit card that
people can be charged they can get an
Airbnb debit card and they can recharge
it to extract money
is really really hard to for people to
get paid cross-border in Argentina so
every time you enter a new territory
there are interesting challenges like
that but if you can solve those early
then you essentially have a foothold and
yeah
so China Bret's a product yeah and the
risk of sounding like a broken record I
mean certainly you know going back to
the earlier question I mean we plan to
be everywhere in every market in every
city where you know the daily deal
business makes sense where we have
enough consumers and enough businesses
that you know want to get new consumers
in the door and consumers that want
deals we believe that that's pretty much
every market out there every every city
almost every town and so we certainly
plan you know to be everywhere we can
and I can't comment I don't have any
real detail that you know juicy secrets
to tell you about China but certainly
China is a market that we're looking
into
I'd say one of the basics is once you
slap it on there you still have to pull
the content pull is sharing because just
left to its own devices it might not
perform but if you coax it in a very
colorful way you really solicited very
authentically have a conversation with
your consumers really pull their stories
pull the share and get them going it's
something you're starting to see more
and more very effective but just leaving
it static on the site hidden because it
kind of gets lost on the page not a not
a best practice but not a lot of
companies yet have figured out how to
get that conversation going and to coax
and encourage people to to share I think
ModCloth actually is one who does it
does a great job but others are starting
to follow I think one of the things
that's really struck me about social
commerce is it's a really way it's a way
in which the consumer and the community
actually owns the brand and they they
participate in it and they promote it
and they work with it and I think that's
what's unique and that's what you see
across the board here today is with
Airbnb you have people you know meeting
with one another spreading it
word-of-mouth becoming extraordinary
ambassadors for each other and for the
brand you see it within one Kings Lane
people are fanatical about the products
that are being sold there they trust the
brand they also promote the brand to one
another and you see that with a Groupon
where people will share a Groupon deal
on their Facebook wall which is very
unusual at the end of the day how often
do you share something that you bought
on your Facebook wall but people love
doing that with Groupon so it's how do
you get your community really actively
involved as consumers to promote and be
a part of that brand I think that's sort
of one of the common ways we build on
that we find we do research and market
so we show up with your focus groups we
can't chase the people out of the room
they stay there
so again so those old-school tactics of
just get your consumers together online
or offline and let them go you'll you'll
win if you can really get those
like-minded people together so this
notion of meetups people meeting offline
and connect them online offline very
powerful instrument to really engender
ambassadors and brand loyalty and get
that promotional effect going I think we
have time for one or two last questions
we majority' revenue comes from outside
the US I think it's a fraction of our
business is just domestic business there
are unique things about people all over
the world
but what surprised us most wasn't how
different people were but how
fundamentally similar they were
regardless of the culture and there were
so many questions about what people have
different expectations about all
different vectors whether it's
cleanliness or hospitality in these
different cultures and yet whether or
not a booking is domestic in other words
whether an American books another
American or somebody from India books
somewhere in the US the review scores
are always consistent there isn't a wide
variety of difference the differences
are always subtle
they're like so our vision is what we've
designed is the booking experience so
the mechanism to connect people and we
don't want an Airbnb experience to be
throughout the home that's a very local
experience we want the Meccan to connect
people and I think just the
proliferation of Facebook nearing what
six hundred million users a lot of these
things and a lot a bay had already gone
through this so a lot of this stuff has
already had already been solved and
we're kind of like that final and maybe
one other thing in our spaces
interesting is what we do is primarily
not an American concept it's primarily
an international concept if there was a
center for us you know our Hollywood
would be the EU so Europe and it really
spreads from there so
any differences I I say agree on that
consumer side not really supply chain
retail infrastructure shipping really
add some diversity in the markets
consumers are are much more similar than
they are different but go find the
inefficiency I mean there's an
efficiency in Europe and supply chains
that companies are taking advantage of
but it's more other sites that are
driving the different models that are
forming yeah it's it's it's 70 Channing
to get more more businesses to work with
us and I think even early on this sort
of limitation of a deal a day was you
know a large part due to the fact that
it's hard to get more partners down
board when you're a small small company
right sort of because of that limitation
not in spite of it for us we do want to
you know continue to roll out and
there's sort of this growth imperative
that we're looking at but at the same
time we need to curate and make sure
we're only working with sort of the very
best merchants and so there's a fine
balance for us as we sort of try to try
to expand how many how many businesses
we work with we try to get better at at
serving the right deals to the right
people at the right time so that can
help us you know doing some optimization
there but other than that it's it's a
bit of a challenge for us to to actually
grow without you know becoming a company
that dilutes the the type of product we
provide
retail requisition I mean I imagine it
to start what you had to be calling the
people are going to talk to them are you
yeah we get a lot of incoming calls yeah
I mean I don't have any specific numbers
but they advertise in American Idol no
yeah no I mean we I think the the sort
of officially sort of you know published
at that's out there as we turn away
seven out of a perchance or we can't
work with we can only work with one out
of eight merchants right and I think
it's sort of speaks to the the concept
we talked about earlier which is just
it's hard to get users it's hard to get
consumers in your door as a local
merchants and you know that's one of the
that's the main thing we're here to do
well Brett Brett Greg and Brian thank
you so much for your time